[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I'm Dana Jacobson from CBS Saturday
morning welcome to the dish it is five
o'clock somewhere right in this episode
we are featuring all types of adult
beverages from vodka distilled in
California to rum made in Connecticut we
start with a Windy City Tavern with
upscale eats and a funky name the Moody
tongue Brewing Company
foreign
Street in Chicago's South Loop sits
Moody tongue a playground of pairing its
12 course tasting menu meticulously
prepared by Chef Jared Wentworth
presentation just gorgeous Chef Jared's
a Master with beers like this pair
caeson brewed by his partner Jared Rubin
what you're going to experience is the
pear and the acidity
complements the caviar and the matsutaki
Chao Moshi which is a Japanese egg
custard so think like scrambled eggs and
caviar
with my normal wear scissors
I'm going to take a sip
that's why I love pairing food with beer
is the carbonation just like in
Champagne those bubbles cleanse the
palate are you really gonna you're gonna
let me finish all right
there's no reason to be here
patient is another story each bite and
sip to be savored with each course
oh my God Chef grew up in the Northeast
he loves nantucket-based scallops
they're so sweet it's like candy almost
prepared with Japanese artichokes and
grits made with a movie theater munchie
that steals the show scallops are like
butter the texture difference with the
little popcorn
popcorn grits oh he actually makes
popcorn and then reduces it down with
vegetable stock
corporates it in there then wash it down
with a little truffle a shaved black
truffle pilsner to be specific I'm gonna
guess it's the food decisions before the
beer decision sometimes sometimes uh
Chef Jared will come down to the brewery
and it'll taste beers and fermentation
I mean this is these are works of art
this is insane you first
Jared I love you already
we'll meet chef in a bit but there are
still two more courses to Revel in I'm
already thinking I couldn't pick a
favorite if you if you made me I
couldn't pick a favorite and that's
always the goal they have to all work
together and it's a progression so this
is our Huckleberry half of ice and my
Uncle Ian sends me these huckleberries
from Idaho every year he pairs that with
squab chanterelle mushrooms sweet potato
and chipoline look at the huckleberries
on Top This is fall on a plate yeah look
at the colors wow we call this pairing
bridging they build a bridge of
complementary flavors and they come
together
shall we
get that out there
I'm coming to your side now I can't stop
and for dessert right now we're having a
Bourbon Barrel aged gingerbread Imperial
Stout oh my it's like a gingerbread
cookie was dipped in a glass of Heaven
hell bourbon I'm a louisvillian bourbon
is really important
and so is beer so we bring these two
worlds together
only topped by
Morris Reuben fell in love with Brewing
at The Culinary Institute of America
where he first started pairing food with
his home brews now it's time to check
out the bird to see weary Brews now
Reuben took us to his secret beer
factory right below the restaurant
welcome to the Moody tongue brewing a
place Willy Wonka might dream up if he
got tired of making chocolate don't
worry I actually pull beer okay from
this Barrel where the only danger is
catching a buzz this beer has been the
barrel for about a year and a half a 12
layer bourbon barrel-aged Imperial Stout
before it's been carbonated
you can almost chew it I mean still
delicious Reuben started Moody tongue
Brewery in 2014 two years later he had a
tap room after a collaboration with
Jared Wentworth in 2019 the pair
expanded opening The Moody tongue
restaurant and bar did anybody think you
were crazy that you were going to go
down this road I mean people think I'm
generally crazy regardless
um but yeah I think people were a little
bit skeptical that you couldn't Elevate
uh beer to the level of Cuisine
um that you know is worthy of a couple
Michelin stars so it really is one of
those we have a good time we don't take
ourselves very seriously we just like
like to feed people the bar at muditung
features an A La Carte menu everything
here we want to be sophisticated like
beat Tartar and whole black bass it's
stuff we can't get away with doing
symbol sized portions of yet has the
same exceptional taste which helped
Moody Tong earn two Michelin stars I've
been blessed and part of that through a
lot of hard work a lot of suffering for
your art essentially I've kept Michelin
stars pretty much throughout my whole
tenure in Chicago I never take it for
granted do we want stars of course we do
like we we work our asses off to get
that for me it's the satisfaction of
seeing a smile on a Diner's face
I think it's the biggest thing is that
instant gratification of making somebody
happy Cheers Cheers
whether it's the beer or the food it's a
feeling which at Moody tongue you simply
can't escape this is our little slice of
cake and then there's nothing little
about this slice of cake oh my God
also I want to warn you that this beer
is like 3 000 alcohol
many you're such a liar but I don't
really know
can I please live here yes
yeah
coming up after the break we will whine
and dine you with some unique pairings
anyone up for Big Macs and burgundy this
is the dish
[Music]
Vanessa price started out as an actress
but later realized she had a unique
talent for complimenting wine with
unconventional Foods as Michelle Miller
found out from Twinkies to Cheetos price
has the perfect pairing
one of the things that makes the Big Mac
so iconic is its Special Sauce right to
Vanessa price it isn't a Happy Meal
without a glass of wine and red burgundy
it's got the same zesty sort of savory
profile as the sauce in the Big Mac ah
and you want a little bit of a tannic
profile which is what protein needs and
you're going to get that from the red
wine in a Pinot Noir has just amount a
right amount of restraint to sort of
make it all work together balance
exactly Price's book Big Max and
burgundy isn't just the ultimate wine
list it's a guy for what to pair with
practically any food or snack you can
think of and the science behind it there
are chapters for food from Trader Joe's
wines for breakfast and even roadside
attractions like Cheez-Its twinkies and
Cheetos sauvignon blanc inherently has
high acidity it's a very crisp very
fresh wine the sort of savory salty
cheesiness of the Cheeto goes well with
that mineral so the flavors get enhanced
I like that don't feel like washing down
a PB and J with a glass of milk how
about a glass of a sparkling red have
you ever had a lambrus go no I haven't
and it looks very interesting like you
have a real tough time opening that
puppy up yeah
this is another one of my favorites
because it's such an unexpected wine so
many people haven't tried Lambrusco
before so you got bitterness from PB and
J you got sweetness from jelly you got
this chewy sort of chunky element from
it all together with the bread because
this is a red wine it's got tannin oh my
gosh the sweetness goes with the people
oh my God and then the bubbles
wash it all clean oh my God Price's book
is also a road map of her sideways
journey to becoming a sommelier in your
original career goals were nothing like
what you're doing now no no no no I she
writes about a chance encounter with
Matt Damon at a nightclub in Miami that
put her on a new course he started
telling the story about how he dropped
out of Harvard to write Goodwill Hunting
and people told me it was crazy and so I
decided I was going to get on a plane
and I was going to go back to Kentucky
and I was going to figure out how to be
an actress price would move between New
York and Louisville for acting school
then College before pursuing acting
full-time and it was only because I
ended up having a college job doing a
little bit of waitressing that I finally
found myself close enough to Wine as a
culture that I went oh this is
interesting maybe I could do this and
you know I didn't actually know what
that meant I just kind of thought oh
I'll figure it out once she had it was
time to tell her father an admiral in
the U.S Navy and he had sort of said so
you're moving back to New York and I
said yeah and he said and you're going
to be an actress and I said no I'm going
to be a sommelier and he turned around
he looked at me he was like a summer
what
over the past 15 years prices worked in
numerous capacities in the wine industry
there's a whole chapter on what to pair
to Cobb salad spinach salad kale salad
including as a wine rep selling to
restaurants like the venerated Carbone
in New York in her book she pairs there
spicy rigatoni pasta with a Chianti I
hear this is the place to eat New York
right now impossible to get a
reservation and to go with this pairing
hold up sorry this is your first time
having it
that melts in your mouth I actually
opened Carbone as an account when I was
a sales rep and this was actually this
wine the queer Bella Chianti was the
Chianti by the glass when carbon opened
I don't like Chianti oh this is It's the
pairing it's the pairing and this is
another level chiantis Cheers Cheers but
not everyone was such an easy sell her
toughest customers have been her
conservative family members my parents
didn't drink my grandparents didn't
drink my grandmother she used to call me
crying because she thought I just got
drunk for a living until one day when
her 81 year old grandfather Hootie did
something completely unexpected he said
you know it's very clear that you've
made your life in this and you seem to
have a lot of passion for it I think
that it would be wrong of me to not try
to understand it ah and so I would like
for Christmas if you would bring home a
bottle for us to try together I I am not
joking I thought my dad was going to
fall out of his chair my cousins were
going this is amazing do they like it I
remember it was like you know everybody
was like
you know just like watching to see what
was gonna happen and I remember my
grandmother sort of tasted it and she's
like it's fine and then you know my
grandfather like we were all sort of
chatting and teasing her and then we
looked over and he'd already finishes
Vanessa price seems to have that effect
on everyone this is an example of a
congruent pairing so it sort of envelops
the mac and cheese yes yeah I couldn't
even go dry for a month in her presence
cheers thank you thank you for going on
this ride with me I appreciate it I
appreciate even more in dry January
you're a trooper no you're a trooper to
do this anything for the craft you know
we now head to Mystic Connecticut home
of the Real McCoy rum owner Bailey Pryor
explains the story behind the name and
the history behind the brand
most people
I have never really had an opportunity
to taste completely unadulterated rums
as the founder and CEO of Real McCoy rum
Bailey Pryor is trying to change that
you have all the same traditions and
techniques that you would have in the
finest Scotch whiskeys the finest cognac
so I can sip rum on the Rocks yep neat
on the Rocks it's beautiful we can do a
little tasting if you'd like without a
doubt
Mystic Connecticut based prior has a
small test Distillery where he can
develop new products
or Expressions he poured us three now
next we're going to go to the five year
you're going to start getting more of
the Barrel in this now you're going to
start to get the lignans and tannins
from the wood so go ahead and give that
a little sip
I'm really amazed at how smooth these
are that's what people tell me all the
time they say I had no idea rum could
taste like I had no idea rum could taste
like this Pryor had no experience making
rum when he created The Real McCoy he
spent decades working in film first as a
production assistant on movies like
Mystic Pizza and home alone then making
documentaries I do all my own research
and I write all my own scripts I direct
my documentary films and so I just get
fascinated with subjects and then I'll
go all the way down the rabbit hole
never more so
than with his film about the legendary
Rum Runner Bill McCoy he's really the
only name you know from the prohibition
era who wasn't a psychopathic murderer
right there's Al Capone and Babyface
Nelson and Machine Gun Kelly and the guy
who refused to break the law Bill McCoy
or rip off his customers like the world
around him
Bill McCoy's life was about to turn
upside down Pryor's 2012 film explored
how the former shipbuilder helped create
the illicit alcohol trade up and down
the East Coast after ratification of the
18th Amendment he was the first guy to
fill up a boat full of rum in January of
1920 down in the Caribbean he sailed it
up to New York City and acted as a
floating liquor store three miles
offshore a loophole in U.S law made that
international waters allowing McCoy to
supply smaller boats which would bring
his rum back to shore
the government had good reason to
silence his Legend
he became the face of rumro other people
would cut their alcohols with turpentine
wood alcohol prune juice water McCoy
never did that so they called his
product The Real McCoy and I just
thought you know that phrase it's such a
household name I wonder if anyone's ever
trademarked it turns out no one had so
prior did then using photographs he
traced McCoy's rum through the tax
stamps on its barrels to Barbados
Barbados is the birthplace of rum so the
tradition of rum producing goes back
about 400 years in Barbados
Pryor and his wife Jennifer headed down
to the Caribbean island in search of The
Distillery that produced McCoy's barrels
they ended up at Foursquare Distillery
home to fourth generation rum maker
Richard Seal so we don't know if that's
where it came from or not but I asked
Richard if he would be willing to work
with us and I said I wanted the kind of
rum that would have been on McCoy's ship
back in 1920 so when someone takes a sip
of this they can taste what tradition is
all about taste The Real McCoy you can
taste The Real McCoy and he said well
that's all we make and that's what
started the whole thing one of the last
family-owned distilleries on Barbados
Foursquare combines the past with the
present in Brewing the key component to
Rum sugarcane is grown on the property
it's turned into molasses and distilled
in a traditional pot still which slows
down the process but adds more flavor to
the rum everything is done in a
sustainable process as you can possibly
do on an island we're 100 produced in
Barbados so we even do the bottling down
there please tell me you are not going
three miles out in the water to pick up
the shipment because they come in we've
talked about having a party out there
Pryor says they're now selling up to 18
000 cases of rum a year after just 1500
in Year One 2013.
he travels to Rum festivals around the
world educating people on how Rome
should taste
and Pryor is so confident that his rum
really is The Real McCoy he lobbied the
U.S government to become the first
Spirit company to list its ingredients
on the label I'm convinced that people
today want to be informed they want
transparency people want to drink less
typically now but they want to drink
better and Bill McCoy became an iconic
moral barometer as complex and
controversial as the era itself to think
back this documentary sort of started
all of this would you ever have imagined
at the beginning of that that this is
where you'd be no uh in fact it was sort
of a lark you know we're like hey this
is fun we'll just do this on the side
you know sell to our friends or
something like that and and uh and then
it just kind of took off
I lift a glass to you and say Cheers
Cheers just thank you cheers cheers
coming up a one-of-a-kind vodka
distillery by the bay we'll show you
next on the dish
[Music]
San Francisco is known for many things
like the heavy fog that often rolls in
from the bay in the spirit no pun
intended or maybe it was a Silicon
Valley Innovation one Distillery learned
how to turn that fog into vodka here's
Lee Cowan with a story that first aired
on CBS Sunday Morning back in 2017.
although you might think that a vodka
still would be a great place to bring in
the New Year
it's actually just a giant teens
if you can't drink any of it straight
out of the tap because at this point in
the process it's 190 proof and just
touch it to your tongue and you'll be
able to get
oh
yep it almost evaporates right oh it
does that's why it's called the spirit
Kaylee Shoemaker is the head distiller
at Hangar One vodka it gets its name
from its home an old airport hangar at
what used to be the Naval Air Station in
Alameda I across the bay from San
Francisco
you make vodka out of just about
anything that ferments but here's
something you might not know
your average bottle
at 60 water is it really yeah it has a
ton of influence on the final flavor
water however is a pretty coveted
commodity in California having just
emerged from several years of drought so
Shoemaker decided she'd experiment with
a more sustainable option and try to
squeeze water out of an icon
[Music]
San Francisco's famous fog it turned out
no one had tried it which I was kind of
surprised about no yeah
all this fog no one had tried it yet a
quick meteorological lesson fog is
essentially made up of tiny floating
water droplets and it turns out those
drops do have a flavor it's water so
it's very nuanced
so that's what fog tastes like it's kind
of like licking a wet Rock but in a good
way it's almost Whispers to the places
the fog traveled and I mean it sounds
kind of silly but with all that little
bit of salinity and minerality you can
almost taste the Journey of the fog I
would say
still coaxing that water literally out
of thin air does take a bit of
engineering
so in its most Elemental form this is a
pea soup catcher
Hangar One Enlisted the help of Chris
falletti who has been wrangling clouds
for years and since this one's up how
much has it collected it's collected uh
more than 700 gallons since we installed
it he's a volunteer with a Canadian
non-profit called fog quest which has
been constructing special Nets to catch
fog in the mountains of Africa Asia and
Latin America since early 2000. in one
Village in Guatemala there are 35 of
those Nets set up together
and capture up to 1800 gallons of fog
water a day
it's a pretty simple process right yes I
mean if you think about it it's designed
to trap the microscopic droplets and fog
yeah you can see it and convert them
into larger droplets which then fall
into the trough
and are collected
here in the Bay Area it can take up to a
day to collect enough fog water to cut
just a single bottle of vodka which
might be because there's less fog in
general so scientist Todd Dawson the
length of time that the fog lingers
around on the coast now has gone down by
about three hours every single foggy day
Nelson is an environmental scientist
at UV Berkeley he says over the last 60
plus years there's been about a 35
percent decrease in the frequency of fog
along the coast and that he says may
have a big impact on Northern
California's other icon the coast
redwoods which depend on fog for both
moisture and fertilization they also
have less rainfall along with less fog
means less water overall and in the
southern parts of the range we're
actually seeing that those Coast
redwoods are really suffering
the lack of fog in part is why hanger
one's aptly named fog Point vodka is so
pricey
how much is it per bottle
retails at about 125 per bottle
isn't cheap no
much of the proceeds will go to fun fog
quests non-profit work as well as to the
California state Coastal Conservancy
bottling San Francisco's fog won't keep
it from thinning but it does remind us
that Nature's resources are worth both
toasting
and saving
[Music]
for more stories like these and live
coverage of breaking news 24 7 stream us
right here on CBS News I'm Dana Jacobson
thanks for watching the dish
[Music]